hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today
we have a little bit of information to
talk about today we have the
roadmap that just came out on the
devstream and then we also have this
weird thing going on on the map right
now that we have to talk about
but as always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new i cover the
informational side of 400 that being the
battle changes the here updates the
patchworks and the leaks
if you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely
subscribe to the channel and with that
let's get started with today's video
so first up like i stated before we have
the july road map
and we're going to just be going right
in order on july 2nd which is today we
have then
arcade quest and some content july 9th
is some
arcade quest and content with the 10th
and the 11th being some small things
like a vancouver challenge and the year
4 season 2
campaign 3 ending so we're going to be
halfway through
with that by then on the 16th it's going
to be
a arcade with some more content the 17th
will have a double
xp fest for the weekend with a warrior
challenge to go with it
the 23rd will have content with an
arcade
campaign 4 is going to be on the 25th
and then there's just content on the
30th
so not a lot of crazy stuff happening in
july other than the fact that pretty
much every week we're getting some sort
of content which i'm totally cool with
but regardless that is there's that and
then there's the xp
so there's going to be some interesting
stuff that you might want to look
forward to
you know come thursday the other thing i
want to talk about is
something i saw on reddit that a lot of
people were talking about and if you go
to the map right now
uh obviously the event is done the
tester medal is
gone sadly but if you go back to the map
there's like this weird
pestilence color kind of infection stuff
going on on the map
and i think this is in reference to the
horcose that we're seeing in the battle
pass
there's a lot of different types of
similar colors to it
but then there's also the execution the
horcos have which is the
tier 100 type of execution where they
like kind of pour
acid on you this kind of at least
to me kind of correlates in some way so
i'm thinking something's gonna happen
with the horcos
whether this is going to be another
event that we get soon
that maybe talks about this sort of
thing or it's just more story stuff or
maybe this content throughout the month
is gonna be all related to the hort
ghost or
regardless we're gonna be learning a lot
about this faction in some way
so i'm very excited to see what's going
to be happening in the coming
months for this game either way that's
pretty much going to be the video it's
not it wasn't going to be too crazy i
just wanted to let you guys know of the
small things that were happening and
mostly because i wanted to hear your
opinion on what's happening with the map
at the moment
because i'm out of ideas really i just
think it's gonna have to do with that
faction
and then that character obviously not a
new faction coming to the game
but a faction within the season kind of
you know the story perspective of a
different group of people we'll call it
either way like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new i cover the
informational side of honor that being
the balance changes the hair updates the
patriots and the leaks
as always guys thank you all for
watching the video and thank you for
making it this far
take care and peace out
[Music]
you